[Music]
do
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
foreign
tear the media's life you're able to
commence whenever you're ready
thank you
welcome councillors to this meeting of
council
this is a public meeting being streamed
live to
youtube and via the council's website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the minutes
i have been advised that the live stream
is now up and running
if for any reason the public can no
longer hear or see the meeting
over the live stream we will adjourn
until the connection has been
reestablished
can i ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for the meeting
and to confirm the members and officers
present
thank you chair uh this is just a
reminder from the chair
that um the members are asked to follow
the etiquette
um for virtual meetings and to act as
you would do
if you were in the chamber can you
remain
with your cameras on throughout the
meeting and also remain muted unless
requested to do so and to speak through
the chair
the chat function is enabled for this
meeting the chat will come directly to
myself please indicate whether you wish
to speak or whether you
wish for your vote to be counted in a
different way the closed captions are
enabled so you may see some messages
coming across the bottom of your screen
and will be issuing polls throughout
this meeting if you have any problems
please message me direct
present in the meeting room today chair
are all members of council apart from
those
who have offered their apologies um
which will offer to you in a moment
when asked also in attendance are the
section 151 officer
monitoring officer at a paid service the
strategic directors
um sarah gordon who is the hr and od
manager
and members of the governance team who
are supporting this meeting
thank you chair
and the apologies for absence
thank you apologies for absence today
have been
received from councillors hearts on hill
holmes huckabee lilly and windley and
all other members are present
thank you declarations of interest
members of it have you got ridgeway
sorry yeah sorry
councillor ridgeway she is sorry
which way apologies to may i uh put in
apologies then for council ridgeway
thank you
members of interest should have declared
them to the governance manager
in advance of the meeting however i will
ask again
can members please indicate if they have
any interest to declare
just an interesting item eight as my
husband is a
council employee
thank you can we approve
can we approve the minutes of the last
meeting as true and an accurate record
councillor barker
and councillor thanks thank you chair uh
uh
louis i don't want it just the last item
uh
and i don't want to go into the open all
that debate up again but
did we not decide at the end of that to
send some uh
acknowledgement to clive councillor
hunt's
contribution to the council and uh and
some thanks
with that i thought we voted on that at
the very end it's no record of that
uh am i writing that and
if that's the case has it been done i
suppose his request
um i can't confirm at the moment whether
it's been done but you're quite right
that was said and it was our intention
to do so i will confirm to you when i've
checked
thank you
counselor dale yeah thank you chad
you're subject to that
that addition to the minutes i'm happy
to uh to move that we accept them
okay is the secondary
voting the government's manager will
issue a poll now
share all members should have the poll
on their screenings asking you to vote
for
against or abstain for approving minutes
of the 1st of february
2021 and that would include the
amendment
put forward by councillor barker
just a few more seconds on the remote
vote
and i'll stop the vote there and share
the results so
remotely we have 41 members that's 100
voting for and two
in the chamber that's unanimous
thank you
i have no announcements today so we'll
move on to item five
i invite councillor dale to give the
leaders announcement
thank you chair can i start by saying a
huge thank you to members staff
and our residents for the fantastic
collective effort
in following the government guidelines
and helping to reduce the spread of the
virus
there's been a significant downward
shift over the past couple of weeks
in our rates locally here in northeast
derbyshire
which means that they're now among the
lowest in the county
and below the national average and this
is thanks in no small part to the
efforts that everyone has made
in doing their bit to control the spread
um
however we must not be complacent the
threat that
kobe poses to our public health
and our wider economy and society
remains a very real and serious one
and i'd urge everyone to continue to
follow the rules very closely
i'm sure we're all looking very much
forward to the restrictions relaxing
over the coming weeks and months
and hopefully coupled with a bit of
better weather and perhaps a haircut
or two but as they do relax we must
continue to stay vigilant and be
cautious
common sense will be required as it
always has been
the vaccinations continue to move at
pace and i'm pleased to inform council
that over 350 000 vaccines
have been administered in the county
which represents roughly a third of our
population
on behalf of the council i want to thank
all those who have been
involved in this huge national effort to
get the country vaccinated
i'm very proud of the way that the
council has been doing its bit to
support the
rollout in a very modest way
particularly at charlie park leisure
centre
and i'm very heartened by all the
positive feedback i'm hearing about how
well
the vaccination centers are run across
the district i just also want to touch
on a few other bits of news we've had in
recent weeks
firstly i want to say a huge thank you
to all of our members officers and
partners
who've been involved in the clay
crosstown board and who have
supported our successful town investment
plan
to have secured 24.1 million on top of
the
500 000 we've already secured represents
an absolutely huge
accomplishment we've been granted all
that we bid for
and it represents one of the highest
allocations of all the town deals across
the country
um it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to to
really transform clay cross and greatly
improve
uh the local prospects with more jobs
being created
as part of the regeneration works and
private
investment drawn in as well helping us
to get even more bang for our buck
um so i know that council renick and her
team will be working very hard over the
coming months
on the plans to deliver what our
ambitious town investment plan
sets out to do and i'm sure we'll all
look forward to hearing more about
it very soon so congratulations to
councillor renick and all
involved on this marvelous achievement
as you'll no doubt be aware there has
been some changes to our recycling
service
following the disappointing news that
our contractor has gone into
administration
i want to thank steve brunt karen hansen
council cupid
uh for working so hard to ensure the
transition to our new in-house service
went so smoothly and largely without
disruption
i'm quite frankly amazed at how quickly
we were able to turn this round
given the urgency of the issues and i'm
extremely pleased that we were able to
project protect
jobs by transitioning the staff straight
over to the council
particularly given the current economic
climate
i'm also very grateful to our residents
for their understanding and patience
with us
given the slight knock on impacts on
green bin collections recommencing
by all accounts the new service is
operating very well and we should be
back to normality very soon
finally as many of you will be aware
following our successful green homes
been
green homes grant beard last year we've
secured another tranche of funding
from the government bringing our total
to date to 1.6 million pounds
on top of this the council is investing
a further 8.5 million pounds
with over 320 homes set to benefit
the works include the fitting of
external wall insulation and the
refurbishment of non-traditional
construction properties
i want to thank councillors kenyan and
powell as well as council officers and
our partners at ricknold for helping to
make this happen
it's a very clear testament to how
seriously we are taking our climate
change commitments
and not only will it help us to see our
targets met
it will also help to reduce energy bills
for our tenants
the works will will shortly be finished
at mickley
and the contractors will be starting
very soon on the next batches of
properties around the district
clearly this will create some
disturbance in some of our communities
but i would ask everyone to be patient
with us as the long-term benefits
clearly outweigh any short-term misused
and finally before i before i finish
check can i um
reiterate that the the chairs appeal is
still very much running uh
and i know that there's an easter uh
picture competition shortly
shortly being uh commenced so i'd urge
all members once again
to to support the chairs appeal and
these two vitally important charities
as much as they possibly can over the
course of the next couple of months
but thank you very much chair thank you
hello
what's
yeah thank you thank you chair yeah just
just on some of that
to alex and it is there's a lot of good
news in there
and i'd like to thank a lot of the
officers as well uh
on all the issues that you've mentioned
i think like say i were amazed that the
recycling thing for it for a fame
to sort of go out to existence and and
for us to pick it up
more or less straight away have been
been a fantastic piece of work
and again the the the 24 million for
clay cross
it it's good news it's uh it's really
positive and
uh let's hope we can uh we can spend it
caroline that's the hardest part
uh i'm making it making it do something
and that's great
and and again i'd echo this stuff
regarding not being complacent
it does feel as though we've we've come
out of covered and we're not quite there
yet
and i went to charlotte park a couple
weeks ago and it was
the the organization was fantastic so
well let's not
uh let's not start celebrating till soon
let's let's make sure we're out of it so
uh
yeah yeah well done
you
councillor and work thank you i also
like to respond thank you uh
councillor dale and i just want to say
actually
um nigel this is absolutely fantastic
news it's a once-in-a-generation
funding boost to play across and
actually the wider
northeast archery district it will truly
be transformational for local people
residents and we're already getting
business inquiries and people want to
get involved now in this deal
so it's it's going to be the whole
district you know we're open for
business
but i just wanted just to say um a
special thank you to
the town board particularly our chair
gary golden
and in particularly officers um gerald
calling and especially
carl apps who's been leading on this and
um also the local community groups and
the parish that have contributed and
it's a great example of conservative
government conservative council working
together
on the level of agenda for our area
thank you
thank you i can confirm that no public
questions have been submitted so we
shall now move to the next item
can i invite councillor paul parker and
portfolio
for finance to present the report on the
level of council tax
2021 to 22.
councillor parker parking
thank you chair and as uh
certainly most of the counselors will be
aware the localism act of 2011
requires also as a billing authority to
calculate the council tax requirement
each year i can confirm today that the
approved amount on the collection fund
in respect of northeast derbyshire is
six million one hundred and twenty one
thousand and eighty eight
pounds in order to collect to calculate
the council tax requirements
the demand of derbyshire county council
the police authority
fire authority and local parish councils
has been taken into account
and the table of paragraph 1.5 sets out
the levels of
council tax for the year accumulating
all
the preceptors demands
the report requests approval by council
for the precepts of the relevant
authorities
operating within the northeast
derbyshire district
area in order for the council as a
billing authority to agree
the council tax liability for local
residents in respect of
2021-22
the council is legally required to set a
council tax for its
area based on the demand of preceptors
on the collective
problem each preceptor approves
uh demand when setting their annual
budget
which we did on the 1st of february
and i'd now like to move the
recommendation at 6.1
thank you thank you is there a seconder
counselor armitage are there any
comments
counselor barker
just a couple of comments i've got
questions really i don't know if you
were
i asked this neil every year and people
have tried
on several occasions to explain to me
the council tech
base and now we arrive at them figures
on that in that table
and it's not sunk in yet so unless uh
all you can have a go at it
or jane if she's there because
i honestly i can't make sense of where
you get them
numbers from yeah and and and
just another just a question really uh
what what would have been like
luckily for the collection of the count
of council tax
because obviously going forward it's
alright setting this but we've got
collected don't we we
are the ones
or actions which is we're not very
popular from that from doing but there
you go
so i'll leave it with you but i'll have
a go explaining the town council tax
base to me
and any other thoughts okay thank you
i'll take that
um yeah it's uh the council tax base is
uh
is based on the number of occupied
properties but it's never
a direct one for one because some
properties are occupied at different
parts of the year
uh and it also takes into account um
properties that are expected to be um
to be in use during uh during this tax
period so
uh this is this is the best i can do
counselor parker to be honest uh it's
never a it's never a one-for-one i
always ask
why it's not a whole number but uh in
actual fact it's because
uh some houses are empty and some houses
are uh populated for part of the year
so um that is my understanding of it
is is that satisfactory chancellor
i think it's it's a fair effort all that
thank you i think it's a mystery to most
people this but yeah
agreed uh and on the collections uh
we're not doing bad on council
council tax collections at the moment
but uh i'll defer to uh
i'll defer to uh officer dethick if uh
if she'd like to give you an exact
percentage
are there any other comments
an update on the collection figures
chair if that if
if that's okay with you um council tax
is actually at 93.87
which is compared to 95.5 last year so
it's one point six three percent that
has improved somewhat over recent months
which is quite
pleasing so council tax isn't doing too
bad that's the good news
the bad news is business rates is at 85
percent
um compared to 94 last year so we're
8.44
down so it's as we'd expect i'm afraid
council tax isn't bearing too badly but
business rates
is down thank you chair
thank you council kenyan yes thank you
chair just uh
regarding council of archer's question
one thing i found useful is to think of
it as full-time equivalence
so the equivalent of um part-time people
working it's like could be 0.7
fte the same thing happens with the
council tax base i believe so
different houses have different uh
council tax levels and they're all
converted into the number of band
d equivalents so a band d is like one
fte
i think that's part of the explanation
thank you okay
sorry
council park m do you wish to use right
to reply
i don't know uncomfortable thank you
chair i'd just like to make the motion
thank you as you are aware a recorder
vote is required for this item and the
monitoring officer will lead us in this
sarah thank you chad uh
as we've been doing we'll start from the
end of the alphabet
please can you tell me if you're voting
for against or abstaining
um councillor p wright
sorry for you councillor b
right
four that's a white head
four four
how's the welcome that's atharca
four
rough
that's a rouse or
cancer row four
council renick four council reader
or cancer powell
cancer pots four councillor pickering
four cancer parking four
council morley council liggett
four that's a lewis
paul councillor kerry
that's a kenyan or cancer jones
councillor hutchinson or
councillor hancock
or councillor hall
four councillor gomez rini
thank you council for now four
councillor mark foster four councillor
angelique foster paul
councillor evans for answer elliot
or that's a dayton or
cancer dale four councillor cupid
oh
[Music]
that's okay bone four
unanimous thank you
can i now invite councillor mark foster
portfolio holder for council services to
present the report of the annual pay
policy statement 2021 stroke
22. thank you chair
um this is the annual pay policy
statement
um which i bring to council for the
consideration
it sets out the council's policy on pay
in accordance with section 38
of the localism act 2011. it also meets
the requirements of the local government
transparency code 2015
which requires the council to publish
such information on our website
the annual pay policy statement for 2122
is included
at appendix 1 for this report the
statement demonstrates the commitment of
the council
on the principle of equal pay it aims to
ensure that the council pay system is
free
from bias it's fair and it ensures
equality
across the board in terms of pay the
statement provides an overview of their
whole workforce and provides some
background on the journey to secure
equal pay over the recent years
resulting in what we now know as the
single status agreement
at the center of this agreement is a
robust job valuation mechanism
job evaluation mechanism which takes
into account the many factors
as detailed within the statement
including knowledge of responsibility
and demands of a particular job rule
the factors are desire devised in such a
way
that a whole range of jobs receive the
necessary recognition and value
whether they're based in the office or
the base of their mobile job
the statement also provides information
about job grades from the lowest paid to
the chief offices
known as the grading structure the
grading structure and incremental
progression points for senior posts are
included
which demonstrate the level of pay at
each increment
a requirement of the local government
transparency code is the relationship
between the salaries of those on the
highest pay and those on the lowest pay
is shown as a ratio and this is in there
we no longer ever as people know we no
longer have a post of a ceo that was
removed in 2020
so this ratio is further closed uh
this ratio is between the council's
highest earner and
of the median the average median earner
and that's 3.9
to 1. other information included in the
statement are
the terms and conditions of service
election duties
shared posts honorary holiday
entitlement financial benefits such as
subsistence and travel
allowance also included is the essential
car user allowance
entitlement um
the statement also includes the pitching
contribution rates associated with the
various whole time pay scales
along with the council contribution
which is currently 14.7 of pensionable
pay
and the final section addresses
retirement arrangements including
flexible retirement re-employment of
employees and receipt of
pension and payment upon termination
of employment so this agreement to the
annual pay policy statement
fulfills both legal and best practice
guidance for employers
and it also supports the council's
equality and the
diversity aims so i'm happy to take any
questions
and i'll answer them if i can
[Music]
any questions counselor dale
just a second uh second in the paper
chair thank you
thank you are there any comments
i'd like to move the recommendations to
italian 6.1 then please
answer shipment um yeah it's it's i just
wanted to know
um when we approved the new structure
whenever it was last year the year
before
are we now comparing what the new
structures cost
compared to the old one because i know
obviously when we were told at that
meeting we were told that we were going
to save the tax on money
um and obviously with this this is
talking about increases etc
i just wondered if we're actually
keeping track just to see
if the new structure is actually costing
us more
yeah uh yeah thanks for that council
shipment there's only two real changes
in this
uh and they've both been agreed before
at council one was the increase in two
thousand
pounds uh in director's salary and we've
already gone through that
previous councils um and the other was
the uh this establishment of the chief
executive post um so we've already gone
through that so they're the only changes
in this
in this pay policy statement yeah
what i'm asking you though is i will
actually keep track just to monitor
if the new structure is actually costing
the council more money so i know one of
the arguments for
this establishing the chief exec at the
time was that it was actually more cost
effective under this new structure
so the question i'm asking is are we
actually monitoring that to know whether
actually that was a good decision to
take in the first place
uh on that if i could uh could ask for
some advice from uh leaking on that
please and see
some detailed information on that
yeah thank you thank you council foster
if i can chair
uh on the question is that of are we
monitoring the cost of the structure
then that's almost a daily task
if i can offer members that reassurance
we're forever monitoring the budgets
through the medium-term financial
planning process
so we're always we've always got our eye
firmly on that in terms of measuring
where we are now to where we were
when the council paper was produced then
these are
these will only ever be a snapshot in
time so when that
report was put through with the savings
projected as a result of the savings
quite clearly the most obvious
change was the removal of the chief
executive
officer role which brought with it big
savings
uh in terms of that whole salary half of
which
north east the derbyshire district
council
saved the other half falls over so
overall
we are probably well not probably we are
still
better off at that very top two tiers
than we were
when we brought that report forward but
obviously as organizations move on
things change depending upon the
ambitions of the council and the
direction
that you take that will always be a
moving piece but we never as officers
will do anything outside of budget every
time we increase the establishment we
come back to council and seek approval
and the business case will be bought at
that point for members to decide
but yes in in in a quick answer we're
always watching council shipment
thank you are there any more comments
now let's have one more if that's okay
no i'm sorry
you've had your
question are there any are there no more
comments
counsellor foster would you like to i'd
like to move to the vote please
thank you
[Music]
nikki can you paul please
yes chair that poll should be arriving
on
memphis screens right now asking you uh
to vote for against or abstain
that the council support the annual pay
policy statement for 21
22.
one vote is just coming in nature
and i'll end the pulling that and share
the results on the screen and the remote
vote
is 441 which is 100 4 with
two votes in the chamber makes that
unanimous chair
thank you
can i invite council mark foster
portfolio holder for council services to
present the agile working policy
councillor foster thank you chair
um agile working policy there's been
many forms of agile work in homework in
and remote working for many years at the
council
and as we know this year the council's
been forced to become even more agile
along with most other organizations uh
that's as a result of covered
and social distancing requirements
and also the extra needs that our
residents have faced because of the
pandemic during the the recovery period
beyond the initial outbreak of covid
we're in a time where we need to rethink
and reconfigure the council's priorities
and how we deliver these
it's a time to explore different ways of
working in order to address the changing
landscape and emerging needs of the
communities
that the councils serve there's an
opportunity here and in some cases i
need to change adapt and transform
the purpose of this policy is to make
some of the processes of working in a
more agile way
simpler and clearer for managers and
employees for both the policy itself
provides a background to what we mean by
agile working and highlights
that this focuses on the needs of the
organization
it also goes into detail the many
advantages of an agile working force and
as you can see there's many
there key to the policy however is that
we ensure responsibility for the
effective implementation of the policy
from employer manager and employees
there are many things that influence
agile working service needs job rule
employee and the manager to name some
clearly opportunities to work in a more
agile way
will be different for each rule waste
operatives for example or caretaking
staff
or cleaners in our buildings don't have
the same opportunity
fragile working as many office or
desk-based roles
that doesn't mean to say they'll be
treated different everyone's able to
actually apply for agile working
the variation in arrangements include
everything from permanently office based
homework in a hybrid of the two flexible
hours
and others as detailed on pages six and
seven
during discussions in the jcg
with the unions um it became apparent
that what seemed to be the most popular
from the feedback we got
was that some sort of hybrid um seemed
to be the most
the policy that was most entertaining
most popular
in some cases the employee's contract
will need to be amended to suit whilst
other arrangements may not
such as working from home or on an adult
basis the policy details how agile
working should be implemented
whether initiated by the employee or the
employer
safeguards are built into this process
to ensure that the aiming arrangement is
fit for purpose and safeguards both the
organization
and the employee for example working
from home for extended periods may have
a negative impact on the individual's
mental health
to safeguard against this an emphasis is
placed against the need to keep in touch
and a sub establishing effective
communication
another example might be the mechanism
for managing the performance detailed on
page 10
or the homeworking checklist which we
see
at appendix 3. so
approval of the policy will provide
clear instruction and guidance for those
responsible for implementing an agile
workforce
the policy will ensure effective people
management which enables our services to
continue to be provided at
high standards that we expect while
supporting our employees
and the organization to work in a new
way a transformative way
and one that's fit for the future i'll
take any questions and answer them if i
can
is there a seconder
[Music]
councillor dale
are there any comments
council ann [ __ ]
thank you chad as well sorry
i'm a okay charity you want to go
council bar first it's
your call
now you can go first thank you
firstly i'm a big advocate of agile
working and i support the intention to
expand availability
however i also have i know that it's
unique but i have the insight of of
having
multiple perspectives on this i'm a hr
manager in my day job
and at two different points in my life i
have actually um
worked from home so i kind of know the
positives and the negatives i've
experienced them
firsthand um the policy says it's
impossible to have one size fits all
and from the council's perspective it's
a very well-written policy that covers
everything the council needs it to
but i would like to ask councillor
foster to accept an amendment on it it's
one thing where we're asking a colleague
asking to work from home or if they're
applying for a job that's on that basis
but where a manager is asking for an
employee to
work from home or work on a hybrid i
think we should have the uh
the ability for the employee to say no
not just go to consultation
the policy itself makes reference to the
fact that working from home can
invalidate the whole household's
insurance
that's not something that affects just
the employer and the employee but the
whole family
and if we've got an employee who lives
with their parents it may not even
legally be their choice
to make that decision some of our
colleagues live alone
so coming into work may be the only
interaction they have with another human
being
for weeks at a time and speaking on the
phone or video conferencing
isn't the same it's different altogether
then of course worst case scenario we've
got
people who may be the victims of abuse
not necessarily from someone in their
own household we've got people whose
neighbors make their life a living hell
and i know the council would look
sympathetic at any of these situations
but the nature of abusers is that they
actually
into people's heads so that they won't
come out and say it and raise the issue
so
what i'm asking for is that we actually
look at including and writing into the
policy the same opportunity for the
employee to say
no as the employer has and
on that basis i'm more than happy to
support it but i would like that extra
safeguarding there for employees
i'll second that okay
all the questions together and castle
barker
councillor parker thank you
thank you chair yeah yeah uh that's an
interesting point
i think that david's raids there but i
am aware that this has gone through the
the the jcg i take it and the unions
have been consulted on it and
and i'm sure they raised them them sort
of issues
my uh we're in in support of it
but obviously it's gone through the deal
process and stuff like that
uh i think i'd i'm personally i'm sorry
i'm sorry
councillor barker i'm sorry my
internet's unstable and cutting out
could ask you to uh
repeat that please remember so sorry
i'll i'll turn my video off so it uh
helps my bandwidth oh sorry about it
i'm sorry it went that good it went it
er
yeah i i thought i was just supporting a
little bit
too for what council hancock said and
shipment but
i take it it's gone through jcg and and
obviously
the unions have been involved in in the
process of this and
uh it's something that i thought they'd
erased
during this process uh just from our
perspective and we are
uh supportive of it and i think uh again
if unions have scrutinized it and things
like that but
there's a couple of things that that our
group sort of wanted to
to highlight and on page three or page
43 of the pack really is
there's a control sheet for agile
working and on the
the next to bottom point that says uh a
date
policy deal for re review a maximum of
three years well
we think three years is too long
especially we've been a new a new policy
and and we covered and home working and
things like that
so we like sorted to consider sort of
a 12 month sort of review on that now
see how it's
progressing i don't know what your
thoughts are on that
and on the next page uh
just on the the policy aims and the last
bullet point
it says to promote a culture of agile
working
that meets organizational needs and
supports
wherever possible employee well-being
and we when we're not very convinced
with that that word in wherever possible
surely uh employee well-being is uh
is something we should do all the time
uh
so it's just the wording of that whether
you can have a look at that
you know it should say oh we always
surely that
uh employee well we need something we
should
ripped up at least not not to not
wherever possible
but anyway that that they were just some
thoughts from our group
so if you if you can just consider those
thank you
thank you are there any comments or
questions
uh yeah i can uh i'll start to address
those then
um the council hancock's uh
amendment to the policy the ability to
say no
uh no i that's something we can't do
uh and we can't bring that in that
ability for an employee to say no
the whole idea is that the organization
should work with employees
and we should come to an agreement um
what an employee should be doing for the
organization
but there may come a time in the future
for example
when we don't have the huge offices that
we've got now i mean for me when you
look at what we were doing
uh 18 months ago we were all sat in the
office all employees were sat in the
office and all the offices were taken up
and we'd never guessed that we'd be
working in hybrid situations we'd be
working like this on zoom
um and it's a long time since i've been
in million but i'm guessing most of that
building
a lot of it is empty and it might be in
the future
that we don't need like other councils
are looking at we don't need buildings
like this
and if you imagine the council and how
it will be
in let's say five years time or three
years time
it might be where some employee
may need work to suit the needs of the
organization
and that's where this isn't a policy of
flexible working
which has been previously centered
around the employee this
is centered around the needs of the
organization or the needs of providing a
service
to residents and the taxpayer now
it is important that we do look after
the well-being which brings us on to
um council of arkansas point
i can't see that bit uh where it says uh
where you mentioned uh i can't see it in
the policy
which says uh wherever possible but yeah
uh
our last bullet point mark on the policy
aimed about
two-thirds of way down
yeah i mean yeah that's the um it is
uh but as for um as for the review
itself that'll take advice
from um from our hr managers or from lee
hicken himself
about the the three-year review the
three of review is there for a reason
i don't know if we can change that i'll
be honest with you but as for the
amendment straight away by saying no
um we can't be party to that um
but thanks thanks for that counselor
shipman if i could
if i could put that question to an
officer about the actual review the
three-year review
yeah if i can answer that chair
you okay for me to then answer that
chair yeah yes thank you
yeah uh in terms of the reviewer i i
don't think that's an issue uh it is a
fast-moving
area i guess uh so a a review
a more swifter review from an officer
perspective i can't
see that as being an issue and obviously
councillor foster's answered
the other points so i don't intend on
making comments on the other points
on that i've got no further questions
i'd like to
um sorry
i'm sorry sarah gordon did we still
speak hello yes i was just going to
make a quick comment on the point the
final point that councillor barker
raised regarding supporting the employee
well-being wherever possible
i just wanted to explain the rationale
behind that is that we get requests
um to facilitate working arrangements
around the individuals needs and they're
not necessarily always going to meet
ensure that the organizational needs of
that so that was why the
um phrasing is as it is within the um
policy however we can look toward that
slightly differently if you wish
i'd support you being worded slightly
differently have you got a suggestion
for
there sarah
we don't need it now it's just it's just
a principle uh
mark if that's okay with sarah and
yourself
thanks for that thanks councillor barker
appreciated
if there's no further questions i'd like
to move to the vote
please chair so can we go to the
amendment
please oh sorry um
with council and cop
right to reply
thank you chair i mean obviously we will
support this motion even if the
amendment doesn't go through i'm i'm
disappointed because it is there in the
interest of safeguarding people so
i would like to see it go in um and i
take council foster's point
um about balancing the needs of the
council health pay absolutely agree
um the the key is that this is actually
a finite thing because
the reality is we're talking about
changing existing stuff and not
forcing a change on them that may
actually endanger them that's
that's what i want to make is that that
safeguard is there
um and as i say i mean we've got the
consultation which does protect that to
a degree
it's those people who are in a position
where they can't necessarily raise that
that's what
my concern is so i do ask
us that you would support it on on the
basis of how it's intended
obviously if you don't we will still
support the motion because agile working
is important
but but we would ask that council back
it
can we just be clear as to the wording
of the amendment
the the amending is simply to is sorry
chair i'm talking
over you there apologist
uh the the amendment is to to include
the option for the employee to decline
um agile working being being imposed on
them
i'm sure i'm sure sarah would come up
with relevant wording if the amendment
were to go through
thank you and it and that was originally
seconded by councillor shipman
so shall we take your vote on that
please
do you want to say anything more on the
amendment counselor poster
can i can i just just for clarity please
sorry i'm not entirely sure
uh because the recommendation here is
just just
the implementation agile working policy
uh as it stands so
are you actually amending the policy
itself is that what you're suggesting
i'm i'm not not ever so clear what we're
voting on that's
i'm just yeah some guidance on that
really
so that's adding that paragraph what
you've said
so yeah uh i think i i can
support that personally i think that's
that seems
that so the employee can refuse if they
want to
is what you're suggesting yes yeah that
would be to give them that extra
safeguard
okay yeah i think i can support that
sure councillor foster on the amendment
uh thank you chair no i won't be
supporting the the amendment for the
reasons
uh given earlier without repeating those
but just to
uh put councillor barca's uh hopefully
concerns
at rest uh like you said it did go
through uh jcg
and we discussed this at length with the
three unions unite unison gmb
uh they asked lots of questions and we
discussed a lot and their main concern
was um was about uh the
mental health of um of the
the employee working hybrid or working
full-time from home
and we do and we felt we addressed that
and at the end of it all when we went
through it
uh because it was a long meeting they
were more than happy to recommend it to
council and as you can see i think it's
in the notes
uh somewhere that the jcg group and the
three unions
recommended as it is to go to council
which is why i brought it
now um as it is as it stands without any
amendments without uh
the employees being able to refuse if if
we look at it practically
that the council and um
and leadership i've got no intention of
suddenly
uh saying to uh employees you must now
work from home you can't come into work
it's not a case of that
it's about it it's about being open and
it's about employees being open
to work uh in different ways uh
and like i pointed out uh earlier if
the needs of the organization aren't met
first that's what we've got to look at
we've got to look at
employees but if the environment around
us changes
you know it's the needs of the service
that must come first and you can tell
with how we treat employees
already if you look at the the leaders
statement was given earlier by alex
thanking but
thanking charlotte charlotte councillor
cupid for the work she did
in making sure that we took those
employees on
from a company that went bust you can
see the sort of attitude we've got
towards our employees and it's one
where we're looking after people it's
not one where we're forcing people to
work in ways they don't want
so i think that more than anything and
that attitude and that approach i think
it shows
you know that we are going in the right
direction that and the full discussion
we've had with the unions
i think uh i think we've done all uh all
we can
uh so that there's a uh i think i've
already taken a comment i think uh
council hancock's already spoken so i'd
like to move to voting to
on the amendment sure it's a point of
personal clarification just on the
council foster was saying there
that the the the issue that i'm making
here is
is not because i i fully accept you've
had all those consultations by
the the mental health implication
everything else the point is those
people
whom this policy potentially could put
at risk because there isn't an option
for them to highlight
that they could be at risk that that's
why i'm proposing the amendment that
that is
the primary excuse me hiccups the
primary purpose of putting this there is
to make sure that they have got that
additional safeguard
it's not to undermine anything it's not
to undermine the discussion with the
unions or anyone else
it's there to give them an extra an
extra safety net
nicker we'll ensure uh a poll on the
amendment
thank you chair members should have in
front of them um
the proposed amendment
if you only vote for against or abstain
just waiting for a few additional votes
to come in
i'll just stop that vote now
chair are you able to give me the votes
from the chamber
thank you so the vote is
uh 15 4 with
27 against including the votes from the
chamber with two abstentions and i'll
just share those results on your screens
now
um and chair for clarity that means that
the amendment is false
thank you
counselor foster do you want to write a
reply
uh i think of uh all of a neat
uh i'd like councils to support this uh
support this policy as it is um
yeah that's it i'd like to move to the
vote on this thank you thank you
we will now go to the vote nikki will
you wish your
paul thank you thank you chair on your
screens you'll now have uh the
recommendations
that are in the report circulated prior
to the meeting you could
kindly vote for against or abstain
thank you uh including the votes for the
chamber
the result is unanimously four
okay
the next item on our agenda is to
consider the purpose
propose sorry calendar of meetings for
the 20
to 21 stroke 22 municipal year
police can monitoring officer present
the report
thank you sarah thank you chair each
year a draft calendar of meetings is put
together and presented to members
in advance of the start of the corporate
year this is so that members are aware
of potential of meetings come meet
so that members are aware of meeting
dates in advance of the start of the
year
there's been consultation with officers
and members
but with regard to some of the dates for
regulatory meetings
there are a lot of legal constraints on
when the meetings can take place
this has been incorporated in the
schedule however under the existing
corona virus regulations up until may
the 7th
meetings can be rescheduled even if they
have been called in any event
even beyond that date if there is a need
for change before a meeting has been
called
this can be arranged this is why the
second recommendation is a delegation to
the government's manager
to be able to do that um we'll try and
answer any questions
thank you chair
any questions
counselor shipment it was just a comment
actually just to say thank you for um
because i know it was raised last year
about the meetings being rearranged at
committee meetings all the time and i've
found actually in the last 12 months
that that's significantly reduced
compared to the year
the time before so i just want to thank
you because it makes me organizing my
own
diary and stuff a lot better
counsellor dale
thank you chad councillorship probably
isn't going to like what i'm going to
say next i'm afraid but
but no it was just just to say happy to
to move the recommendations but do note
that obviously recommendation two
gives us a bit of latitude i believe
that there are a couple of chairs
uh particularly the regulatory uh
committees who who weren't
um uh sort of cited on the on the
proposed
dates uh prior to them being set so
there may be one or two tweaks um that
they may wish to make
with governance i'm aware that
governments have worked very hard to
put the calendar together so obviously
we would aim to minimize any
any changes as much as possible um
because i know there's a lot of
coordination and hard work that goes
into it but
just to make that point that um i'm
aware some
some shares may want to make some slight
tweaks and if
if that can be uh allowed as part of
these recommendations and maybe
uh the final calendar brought back to us
at a later stage
uh in the next meeting or or thereafter
would be very good
so i'm happy to move the recommendations
on on that basis
is there a secondary
council armitage thank you we will now
commence voting
the governance manager will issue a poll
nikki
should be on your screens now members to
vote for against or abstain
making sure all the votes are in uh with
um
two votes for from the chamber and 42
votes for
on the remote vault that is university
caricature
thank you i can confirm that no
questions have been submitted by members
under procedure rule
9.2 so we'll move to the next item on
our agenda
i can confirm that no motions have been
submitted from members under procedure
rule 10
and i have no urgent business to declare
so
meeting is now closed thank you
you